good morning Millennials welcome to a
very special episode of the morning
shows we're shaking things up like it's
Chicago in here and we are starting with
our guests here today who is you know a
famous Chester a famous businessman a
famous fan of Cher
it is the one the only the points guy
also known as Brian Kelly and you
recently rebranded your Instagram how
was that going by the way going well
although Instagram is so freaking weird
these days like I get tons of new
followers a day but then unfollowed
but I saw and I'm not a fake insta
person yeah yeah I was like waiting like
watching the comments when you were
calling people I said no one called me
up for being a fake I've never bought
I've never paid a bot no I love calling
I was no there's some housewives who are
out of control the Russian BOTS like ya
know like you can always tell when
someone's Instagram is really fraudulent
cuz they get all their likes in the
first 10 minutes which is not how
Instagram works and I'm ready for the
reckoning though it's not here yes I'm
here I keep checking the people who I
know are going down hmm and it hasn't
happened but I look forward to the day
well today's a special day and the
reason why the points guys is here is
because it is the first ever and it's
gonna become an annual fellow for sure
sure
the points Chi Awards the TPG Awards
which will be at somewhere II will be
covering it live so make sure to follow
us on Instagram snapchat Facebook
Twitter and all the other places I go
with a joke club and son job jackieo
problems public no job with no job
martyr will be there Olivia will be
there just make sure Pentium III I guess
you could follow Brian Kelly too if you
want and the point guy and it's gonna be
legit like it's not gonna be someone so
drunk this was like me as like a gay boy
growing up and like the suburbs of
Philadelphia like dreaming at night like
one day I'm gonna throw a party on an
aircraft carrier fabulous pop star we've
got bebe Rexha oh my god I don't know if
we can say that list gives me chill
you've seen it well I like it
well I'm obsessed with bebe Rexha and
like I just really want to know what
goes into the planning of an award show
like with this kind of budget because I
remember like months ago you were
showing me lists of talent that we're
available and within your budget and
like I just want to know tell the T like
which is a las ocho all the t today I'm
gonna really good okay so we had 300
grand for this event
which is like in New York City's not a
whole lot of money that's because most
weddings yeah so we're gonna have like a
hundred fifty people Twitter people and
then we went out to our advertisers like
Amex Chase City and we're like okay so
for you know a couple hundred thousand
dollars you can sponsor it and literally
every single one was like done John John
I'm like crap I should have charged more
of course all the sudden we had over a
million dollars in sponsorships nice and
we had 300,000 plants so the events
gonna right now in tomato pie come on
1.3 million and we have 500 guests we
have influencers from around the world
we've got Kathy looking at to captain
Sully which get this so January will be
the 10-year anniversary of the flight
that went in the Hudson eight years Zoe
I've never met Sully I hear he's amazing
yeah and funny enough to make it about
me I was on a flight I flew that morning
from LaGuardia to Philly like 20 minutes
before that flight so when I landed in
Philly I had all these text messages
like oh my god oh my god because I was
on my facebook I think I'm like oh I
adore LaGuardia it's a hellhole and then
I went dark because there's no in-flight
Wi-Fi back in those days
oh what a time oh yeah it was really
about me but I remember watching it all
go down but the big day our parents are
the CEO of our parent company Rick Elias
was on that plane with Sully with Sully
any son saved his life solely saved his
life and he's never they've never met so
tonight at the tbg award to be the first
time he'll see Shane face the man who
saved his life and to Rick Elias if you
google Rick Elias tag TED talk he
actually did a TED talk on the things I
learned when I thought I was gonna die
in a plane crash oh it's a minute I got
amazing touch my sister Jackie actually
did a TED talk about Sully and the dogs
have you have you seen it it's very
famous I gave you the brief overview
this morning just about the fact that if
there were chuck dogs on this ugly
flight like they all would have gotten
down go check caps is that still think
I'm less worried about I'm less worried
about the cats to their chili if cats
were going down they wouldn't really
like you know they're sleeping yeah
those are very like us so that's when I
really became an advocate against check
dogs
I don't think so even knows the effect
that he's had on me what are you wearing
by the way so I have three outfits
oh shut up you are such a housewife at
her weddings your house I bet her third
like I have this really beautiful likes
suede Tom Ford
ladies it for the cocktail party so
people gonna think Oh Brian he's a
successful businessman and he's very dim
you entrepreneur and then let's just say
razzle dazzle I get chills thing about
my outfits but you know said the credit
cards its Blacky side slash dressed to
impress yes and worship of credit cards
and what could be more boring right this
is gonna be like the most fun didn't
worry about money yeah nowadays so what
you've been where he's having a hard
time a tuxedo I think just have it you
can walk you can do whatever you want I
think that totally worth suit there will
be people in suits you can wear like fun
jeans and a blazer no I think he wants
to go hot let go all the way and you're
gonna say what are you gonna what are
you gonna talk about four five you've
got five or six minutes to give us like
so I have been given the honor to just
do a brief set and you know I have a
show and a lot of my show has to do with
traveling so it seemed like the perfect
match but I'm thinking of writing
somebody material cause like you deserve
it and a lot of my own material like
disparages companies that will be
sitting in the audience so I'm not
trying to you know embarrassed anyone
except for Brian so I think I'm gonna
write some new material strictly about
what it's like to be friends at the
points that I have to say so why
wouldn't your show in Charlotte yeah and
I took like 30 of my employees that who
are based in short we had the best time
of our lives
we had the best time afterward I'm still
hung over no I will never be the same
and you know oh so crazy like we just
didn't stop during me like I was
drinking up until like the time I went
to say me a burger brought our beers
home like we were being nuts and the
place was so weird because you kept text
me the bar 365 or whatever and we're
like we pull up it's a house I was like
where the hell is Brian sending us and
you walk in it's like a full-fledged bar
just like like someone's dead lit yeah
it was awesome it was really fun I know
but like I'll never be okay and then I
went to Miami afterwards and I just
didn't survive well you told me you
didn't drink is it true she didn't drink
in Miami that's not true no but I toned
it down a lot like for whatever is you
are a compulsive liar
that is true too yeah actually that is
true but like more so just like maybe
you just didn't remember that you 500%
drink but I wasn't at the level that I
wasn't you're about try party or at the
level I could have been for a being a
woman in Miami
it was all more measured and like you
stopped drinking an earlier point like
thinking of your hangover long weekend I
can't yet put you guys on blast oh like
wearing the Bachelorette sashes and
stuff like that you didn't like our
sassy sashes like like the club aren't
you just like a little bit like Japan in
the Bahamas it was like literally that
have you been to the SOS box I think you
should go because I think you should
write a positive review about it cuz we
loved it we loved and it's very everyone
there it's like there's no couples it's
all like the Bachelorette and bachelor
parties linked groups couples like
hangin out and so it's almost gonna come
down that we can't you shut up because
the sashes were a warm welcome everyone
loved our sashes in Miami we were like
in the real world and like I did you
know a lot of gay bars are now banning
bachelorette parties cuz they get you
like rowdy they come and disrupt the
ecosystem
bachelorette parties are honest look at
the worst gay bar in New York I love
Barracuda that's bad but you're always
talking about Barracuda well Tina burner
is like my favorite drag queen in the
world she's and she performs actually
performs there in a bunch she's like the
hardest-working drag queen in New York
like you'll see me like Barracuda on
like a Thursday night you and this day
is like working so hard oh yeah we know
what's night Tuesday yeah like after
that after Oh will you where's the
after-party official well the official
after parties by Hilton with me I'm
already spinning on the on the intrepid
but that's still like 12:15 and then I
don't know I don't make it to the
tomorrow I'm giving the TBG awards like
my whole heart and body like I'm I was
planning on not drinking till Olivia's
wedding but then I forgot about the TPG
award so I haven't drank in the last
three days did you travel and you drink
when you travel or to less than one of
my Delta flight home and I know you love
Delta
I like Delta they're so nice I don't
really say that cuz you know like I like
it but like I get it like the employees
are nice but it's just not so what's
your favorite domestic airlines and
JetBlue min like crows to coast cuz you
get like you can it has free pass Wi-Fi
yeah that's innate like on American
Airlines you pay 50 bucks for dial-up
speed no shrieking I forgot JetBlue it's
cool even if you've like I fly I will
fly coach on JetBlue the legroom is
crazy
yeah not sponsored by any
no I like JEP leeches like through it
I've never gotten to a place with my
true blue points for them though that's
one downside I mean it's kind of funny
the point Scott that their points aren't
that great but like you know like times
our most precious resource I can point
to but like to be on them I couldn't
read like categorize I have to tell you
something I can't believe I forgot to
tell you about my experience with
American Airlines is that what we flew
to Miami
yes so you know people always talk about
why the left flap bed because you can
fly JFK to Miami they're flatbed can I
tell you something we definitely didn't
know definitely do not let me tell you
the one you asked me about flying to
Savannah
from shore the one flight thing where
you get a flatbed can I tell you so
here's the thing people always talking
about LaGuardia it's like the worst
airport and I'm like please I [ __ ]
love LaGuardia because Delta in
LaGuardia it's a brand-new terminal it's
really fancy and they're pretty much on
time so like I'm happy with it
but now having flown American Airlines I
knew what people were talking about what
I'm talking about the Guardia Oh Annie
Annie ends is like the only food option
Sky Lounge is a [ __ ]
horrible and we were just not having I'm
little SIBO Express I went to get a
yogurt I was starving what did he know
nothing branded it was standing in the
refrigerator like climbing on the step
on the shelves of the refrigerator and I
thought that's the only thing that would
get me too naughty
so we rolled up at the airport we were
the big group I mean we're gonna be nice
and like do coach with everyone and we
were like we go to for desk and we're
like Ramona flute coach in the middle of
the plant a toaster actually says yes
she flew it to Miami and like the middle
but they're filming doesn't there no not
like it was like a month ago okay I will
make the people she's a woman at the pan
she's a woman who supports other women
so we roll about desk and we're like yo
hook its up we need season first class
and there were none left so we're like
all right well some in the back with
everyone else and reporting the plane
and there was you know there's two lines
like one for oh you're like 1988 you
show up what can I get my ticket now I
can operate the first-class Delta I can
do it all on my phone American Airlines
I don't have I'm not special with them
I'm not invented so I'm shocked you
didn't get an upgrade decided as we were
walking into the airport that we wanted
yeah we were gonna be team players but
then we didn't want to be anymore
but whatever it blew up in our faces and
there was two lines to board there was
one for everyone and then there was one
for me
and
I go to the front and I like make myself
a target just by being a [ __ ] and this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] woman who looked
wasn't even she wasn't even assigned to
this airline she was just like your bags
to bag and I'm like oh it's so annoying
you know I'm like no it's not like I'm I
have one bag I bring it every time like
I started getting teary eyed thank you
so much for trying to keep me safe yeah
thank you so much for doing your job
anybody recorded it and so the chamsy
like it would be my my least fine moment
I was so upset and I was like no it's
not and they have that tiny little thing
it's like if it doesn't fit in here I'm
like that's not real I get on the plane
it was the overhead bin space that they
have on the Delta one from LA to New
York the biggest thing I've ever seen
and it was empty above my seat I was
crying on the plane I was upset and then
the most annoying part is I could deal
with a gate check yeah okay check is a
check but they made go to the and at
Miami Airport it takes like one hour on
average she was so far I would you
except for cabs because it was so far
okay for some more cabs
well we couldn't fight figure out the
uber thing you are the worst traveler in
the world I actually stopped telling
people you're friends with me because
these stories are like Brandon I know
but that's the thing with group trips
like have to do whatever I want when I'm
on my own I can find my uber and like
uber my I see
yes and it's like oh it's so illegal
like there have three different times
I've been at Huber's in Miami where
they're like oh [ __ ] I got to get gas
I'm like I think you can meet her kept
running whatever but that's crazy
okay make sure we get the yeah question
for you what is the best carry-on bag
that's the biggest best bang for your
buck that you could fit the most if you
could only have one carry-on bag wow
that's a great question oh like because
I have this dsquared one that is
actually an inch and it is leather and
it expanded I can go I went to Europe
for a week with like my shoes on there
just to carry on but it's super
expensive so it's not for like it's not
it's not good yeah we actually have like
a bunch of gear reviews I don't know if
there's like we probably should yeah
actually Samsonite sponsoring our ward
like they're giving you guys we'll all
be getting cool Sampson I carry on so
you have to try it out I just want to
get and they know everyone's on hard oh
yeah but yeah I don't like our gel like
no
stop it hate it have a hardship I know
well cuz I just can never get the clasps
like some well I don't special check
luggage like the ones that of clasps
that are like metal and they look
beautiful
they're like a pain in the butt no I'm
not into our child okay you are also
besides from being you know the points
of extraordinaire you really the credit
card guy and you get great
recommendations I have the Chase
Sapphire reserve because of you and I
think millions of people do too so we
got a lot of toaster questions very
specific about certain credit cards for
certain situations probably the most
popular question we got is we just
released tickets to camp tous and
there's $150 and someone a bunch of
people who just aren't liquid want to
know your thoughts on the best credit
card to open right now that has like the
least risk that will help you then pay
for the ticket yes so if for toast I
would say chase freedom it's a no annual
like I special for like beginner
toasters you get $150 just for getting
the card okay I think you have to spend
$1,500 or something like that how long
okay do you know how much you 500 it's
like super easy so that's under $50 off
toast right there I haven't you spend
they can get $100 that's your campus
yeah and you earned one point five
points for everything you spend so that
would definitely and it's no annual fee
it's like probably that's like our best
like overall cash back card because your
good thing about the chase freedom
unlimited is that you if you graduate
and you say you want to you come a rich
[ __ ] like you guys and you want the
Sapphire Reserve the chase points when
you get the higher sapphire cards from
freedom you can actually move your
points up they become more valuable as
you kind of graduate and stay with you
chase chase points are you know the
transferable points the most valuable
you roll over they roll over there they
never expire as long as you know you pay
your bills and everything this is a good
question and primary millennial ask how
does a millennial spender who just
spends on like groceries gas drinks rack
up a lot of points without making huge
purchases I feel like you have I have so
many points but what do you actually buy
yeah so for like the urban millennial
especially that's like doing seamless
and red eating out so the new Amex just
refreshed their gold card which now
comes with four points per dollar for X
so this Reserve which you pay for in 250
dollars for on the Amex gold which is
only 250 right Kate a year I'm like
making sure
two-fifty just double-checking you get
four points per dollar in all US
restaurants which includes seamless
restaurants and supermarkets Forex on
all of that so even if you want to like
you know it's good yeah and then there's
other categories as well and actually
until if you get it until January one
they have this like rose gold edition
it's a toasty very toasty so it's a
metal card drop it on the floor
yeah well sorry I'm desecrating your
studio excuse me but its just a cool
rose gold until January 9 25,000 points
and 4x on dining and grocery stores and
then 3x awesome airfare and other
categories that a lot of toasters spend
in so the MX gold is really cool looks
points are good points and exports are
really good points you know the thing is
you want to diversify someone has to
chase some am i right and I know ya
agnostic you so you want to be good
about your your credit score if you have
a premise article or 700 or above you're
gonna get a proof for most of these
cards you don't need to be making two
hundred thousand a year at the AMEX card
you just need to be really good with
your credit and I don't recommend I
really strongly do not get credit cards
if you're in debt and trying to pay it
all down focus on paying your debt off
because these cards do come with high
interest so if you're paying 20% or even
15% APR and you're earning like these
points which are worth like a couple
cents apiece or five even if you're
gonna be losing so I want to heavily
heavily heavily stress financial like
smartness and responsibility if you're
not at that point yet as much as I love
points we don't get credit card that way
pay him off but once you get into that
where you can pay it off in full every
month that's when you win at the points
game have you seen confessions of a
shopaholic I'm not oh my god yeah that's
a CEO because not only is it everything
that you talk about but you are like the
modern Becky bloom would just it's
making credit cards accessible to people
you have to see it like today today I
know your buddy maybe tomorrow you have
to know when you're getting your glam
done I can't believe you haven't seen it
it will successful savings men like you
were the reason I left Finland you have
to prove it exactly it's like I
and amazing but also so much great yeah
that's series of books and all the books
are great but if you just see the movie
has so much to do with what you're
talking about so choking down a credit
card and paying them down you are the
girl the green scarf you're the girl in
the green scarf gonna wear a green scarf
from the toes okay this is I'm Jordan
Fitbit ik what's the best credit card if
you don't travel often if you don't
travel so you just want to get a
cashback card so we said to chase
freedom the city double cash is probably
the best cashback card you get one it's
basically two percent cashback and no
annual fee the chase freedom unlimited
you get a sign up bonus and it's one and
a half percent but then you have the
ability to upgrade down the line but if
you want straight-up cashback Citi
double cash one percent back when you
charge and then one percent when you pay
it off so that's probably the best
all-around cashback card but you guys
this is a lot of information but we're
taking care of it don't worry because we
we wrote all this up for you guys cuz
it's a little confusing and I feel
overwhelmed sometimes with credit cards
because like everyone has their own like
stick like sometimes you travel
sometimes you don't sometimes you're
very sometimes repor so we've put it all
together and a link for you guys on the
points guys so we'll give it to you
later just don't you don't need to take
notes just enjoy just enjoy the ride how
many credit cards is too many credit
cards like what's a good number to have
I mean I would say a good number to have
is you know for a beginner just getting
like to the thing is these credit card
bonuses are huge so and what I will say
is like I'm gonna on the cheaper cards
which we've been talking about like
you're not gonna get a huge sign up
bonuses there is one card right now the
Chait or the Capital One venture card so
you get 75,000 points if you can spend
five thousand within three months which
so it's like you know a lot of people do
that it's seventy five thousand points
I'm not allowed to say when that offers
ending but you know but it's but it's so
that's the venture card and venture just
now allows you to use those for travel
or you can transfer to airlines and the
transferring an airline games when you
become like a points pro that's what
we're talking about early that's when
you really get tons of value you're
flying in business class to bali your
friends are like so the point is so like
if you have Amex points chase points
capital one point city thank-you points
and the in the right cards you can
actually you know if you go to book
travel through them a $500 flight
usually is like
50,000 points right but 50,000 points
when you transfer to United it's like a
first-class round-trip tickets you have
to find a ward availability so you can
change credit card points to airline
points a lot of them you can tell that
the double cash and the freedoms you
can't okay but when you get the
sapphires in the Amex gold and the
capital one venture so this is how you
win the points game you get the car it's
like Amex goal that's giving you for
Exxon you're dying in and then the
venture card gives to Exxon everything
so you never want to be earning less
than 2x per point right so that's us
points Maximizer you'll use just
different cards for different things so
if you're using one card for everything
you're playing the game wrong okay so
right now it's like a hundred thousand
Chase Sapphire points you don't
recommend booking a flight through their
actual good stuff just to give you a
hundred thousand points will get you
fifteen hundred and flights cuz what
sapphire reserve chip the premium car
they're gonna give you one and a half
cents that's decent but the hundred
thousand points transferred to you can
use eighty thousand points transferred
to Air France and book round-trip
business class to Europe which is like a
five thousand dollar flight so would you
rather have a fifteen hundred ollar
coach flight to Europe or be smart
transfer to Air France and book business
class this is less miles so you can fly
business for twenty thousand less miles
by understanding these transfer partners
right and it so takes a little bit of
work yeah and there are risks because
you have to like see if there's
availability on certain days but most
transfer partners go instantly and who
transfers with you like hookah so it's
very dizzying so right now we if you
google the best way to use Amex points
or chase points we have post at our live
transfer to this partner for this or new
app that's gonna be coming out like
yesterday so the new app is gonna track
your points it's gonna you're gonna be
able to link up through plaid which is
what allows you to link to mint and all
those other we're actually to look at
your spend and will tell you this card
that card so wait you can in your app
you're gonna be able to like log into
all your everything is gonna be under
one house we're gonna tell you how many
points you have how much we value those
points and then we're gonna have this
whole trip planning portal where you're
gonna say I want to go on my honeymoon
to Bora Bora we're gonna say well you've
got Amex and chase and we just bought a
company called expert flyer which I've
been using for 10 years expert flyer
actually syncs up to the airlines and
sniffs out availability so in one app
you're gonna track your points we're
gonna make sure you're earning as
any possible you're gonna be able to
plan a trip and so if you say I want to
go to Bora Bora we're gonna be able to
say well start using this card more we
want to get your chase points up instead
of a mess well if you followed that so
we have a whole team my next question
about reward stock which is the app that
went on Shark Tank and I watch episode 2
days ago and I was freaking out because
I'm like oh my god this guy delivery
stole the points guys whole shtick and I
actually even went on and I became a
member I paid the $29 I'm gonna bet they
want to see with this at least on I'm
not [ __ ] please recycle later but gbg
they don't even do free she got you got
defrauded don't say it's a fraud because
that's a strong word you have to
manually put in your point so like how
many delta points you have yeah it's
gonna pull it all do everything so we
just did it one more thing example he
used on on Shark Tank like if you want
to go to the Maldives I'm like so I
tried to search my own oh yeah there's
only 30 destinations so doubling so we I
said cuz I'm lazy so I put my best
writer on it one of our best points
writers Jason Steele and the post went
live this morning because I knew we rose
we had it waiting and I was like I'm
going on the toast publish and no we did
it there's only like 20 airports to 20
destinations or 30 it's like it's janky
bad phone service they promised the
world they under-deliver and I think as
a as an entrepreneur I'd rather wait
I've been working on it with the team of
20 people yeah so when our it's not even
a competition I'm not worried about
rewarding and I do encourage anyone
should I encourage other bloggers who
are coming or show yeah we're working in
a space that I'm comfortable with but
reward stock it's you know it's what
we're building and it takes a lot of
hard work and grit to do it but they
like went on Shark Tank and promised it
I'd I think I think it sucks that you
basically lost your mind no I'm sad and
you can't even use the interface without
becoming a member first so it's like
really trickery of course you got to pay
and then you're late and then wait a
minute yeah so to go on national TV and
say oh your trip to the Maldives and
then Oh Maldives isn't one of the 20
she's 29 now it's like to double in on
me I don't want to go to Dublin yeah
that's so [ __ ] up it was I'm sorry
obsess but your app is coming what
that's 119 q1 20 hopefully q1 and also
we're launching I just hired people
the UK we're launching in person I met
them they're so cool every bit the words
tonight you want you podcast podcast
talking it's called talking points which
is just the greatest thing I love the
pockets is really fun I've always been
told I have a face for podcasting I mean
it's so fun because you can sit so what
we do is we talk with like senior
executives we talked with Richard
Branson about virgin but then what we do
is we sit down for the second half of
the episode with our points experts Zack
Koenig who knows United Richard Kerr who
knows like I learned stuff doing this
podcast and my holy crap like I did not
know you so we go high level about the
airline and then our expert digs deep
and it's like this trick that trick this
is how you get upgraded and you really
like high-level fun and then we like
drive home like these cool podcasts now
and apples something happened to Claudia
I recently and I want to know what you
would have done if you were in our
situation and we're affectionately
calling it the divine diversion but we
were in Nashville we got to be careful
what you say about Pittsburgh cuz I went
to the University of Pittsburgh nothing
but love for Peter the most prestigious
city are live okay good good good we're
in Nashville for the CMA Awards red
carpet whatever now that's a Hollywood
not as big as some IG Ward's budget show
pretty cool
we got to the airport in the Dells of
Sky Club our flights about to board in
20 minutes we had a notification and
it's canceled
out of nowhere out of nowhere we're dead
find out there's a storm coming to New
York it was obviously the storm of the
season that the city was not prepared
for and the charter a plane all thanks
to our mayor sir probably gonna text
about it I was watching your story like
I'm getting a text any minute but
instead of more looks like that you
don't any like right how do I save $10
on the one flight again to this place I
don't know
so we're in the sky club soon they get
us on standby for the next flight and
then get us on the 4:30 our flight was
suppose to be at 11 we wind up taking
off around five we get diverted to
Pittsburgh we have to stay the night the
next morning our flight is rescheduled
for Pittsburgh no we went to God we got
into the hotel at midnight upwards kind
of far too oh my god I'm freezing it was
storming there too so we didn't get our
whole travel day
about 28 hours what would you have done
what do I get from the airline for that
I'm you do Hey you will not get anything
from the airline it's not the airline's
fault the airline kept you safe right so
this is right no sorry the next day once
the flight had cleared we were four
hours delayed because they didn't have a
flight attendant whatever because I mean
the thing is the whole system this is
where I will say you've got to just go
with the flow you really do our air
traffic system like unless it's like
mechanical I mean when the weather
really throws everything even if it's
not showing in your airport there still
can be delays so that's why I say to
people just chill out like you you can
get riled up or and expect compensation
for your time but like there is a part
of just travelling where you get to sort
of release it you gotta let go because
people will stress themselves out has
anything like that ever happened to you
because you travel so much I do but you
know
Mehcad planes they're machines and
they're identical they're gonna break
air traffic control is so congested in
New York so you're always gonna be
delayed you really just have to plan
ahead and and just go with the flow I
mean we all think we're so busy and we
have to have to get their recognized
that we actually I would just say - and
the frontline employees at airlines make
no money and should just always be nice
to them I couldn't believe being brats
just like I don't know I think it's a my
travels of mindset and like you just
gotta go with the punches what do you do
when you see someone like being so rude
to like a flight attendant gate agent
I'll stand up I've stayed behind a
flight and I'll put like I don't know I
saw this that guy was crazy
oh you're yeah but in general I
generally I'm like a non conflict person
on planes cuz people get wacky I'm happy
flemeth fight yet I don't know you can
enjoy getting to the airport five
actually did we um we bladed alright
that was a premium like that song yeah I
can beat my best behavior no but like
when you fly with me like Pharrell come
miles is gonna die on that he'll it was
really pleased it was seaplane seaplane
right which was just scary it was a
little bumpy too much less no I'm not
nervous
oh you know Marisa no you weren't you're
telling me about how the helicopters
were going down in the seaplane really
good if I'm afraid of a seaplane
I think that's very recent all that's
always scared to say are you gonna be
starstruck when you meet so late at
night at least
and what is it about solely we arranged
a photo like just the movie and the
story and then like he's just such a
hero it's and it's not every day you
know yeah it is that point could have
easily crashed killed at one apiece for
his split-second decision this man in
his leadership and like saving a lot I
mean that's pretty amazing
so you said we're gonna cry tonight I
want to under promise and over deliver
award stock so what is your favorite
airline to fly four plus 12 plus hours
in terms of comfort value I love
Emirates first-class you can use my
you've got to do it it's the a380
Emirates first-class you have the shower
in the sky heated floors know you can
use your points you can transfer chase
to Korean air Korean air as a partner of
Emirates think this is where like us
insiders know this stuff I don't weigh
you think when I'm flying all these
fancy flights no you I'll pay for
flights in the US because like it's not
worth it to use your points 500 hour
flight I'll just buy okay but like these
like $20,000 flight to everywhere I go
almost exclusively because we spent like
a million dollars a month on our
Facebook ads like that I'm like Amex
when you get the point yeah so I earn
like every month three million points
just you know 50 employees no big deal
Amex because we you know Amex Platinum
gives five and just finishing out the
cards that are gonna be on the toast
list Amex Platinum is best for perks you
earn 5x on airfare but get you into the
Delta lounge yeah and you get uber
credits airline credits so it's five
hundred fifty dollars a year but two
hundred a year and airline Twitter new
uber so you're paying 150 dollars in
Amex Platinum you're earning 5x on
airfare and for that hundred fifty
you're getting into centaurian lounges
Delta is where you by delta lounge
access alone at 600 so you're basically
paying 150 year to have an Amex card
with good customer sir I just got the
Amex Platinum business because she beat
you told me to yes what else stays cheap
is expensive when it comes to credit
card the no annual fee in the cash back
and I know a lot of toasters are like
just want to get my feet wet but that
you're not gonna get big signup bonuses
and with most of these cards you can
recoup the annual fee right once you
start looking at the perks and you know
the higher fee cards you get better
customer service I bought like a
Montclair jacket when I went to Iceland
last year I lost sticks we're shooting
and Amex because I bought on platinum I
just called up they just took the 2600
ollar coat instantly off the bill so
purchase protect if you have an Amex no
purchased
protection no the insurance so there's
points which are great and then there's
perks you know city have you put stuff
on a city card the prestige card they
have flight delay so if your flights
delayed you automatically get $300 to
like using a hotel what's that one
called the city prestige card it's
actually not out right now it's gonna be
launching in January but if you go go
like we have a post like on flight delay
coverage if your flights can't or if
your bag is lost their credit cards that
will give you automatic like 500 bucks
to buy stuff so we should probably do a
follow-up post yeah I'm gonna promote so
the points go calm / to the porch better
come so it's also in the link in our
Instagram bio it's the the point sky.com
/ chose it has links to all the credit
cards that we just spoke about and in
full transparency we say we make money
on credit cards that the points guys a
free site and we work with the credit
card company and we have a partnership
with the toast so full disclosure I'm
gonna go I'm gonna open another credit
card cuz I only have one personal credit
card you said it's good to have at least
two yeah you have a couple so what else
so and then like a Capital One venture
for sure okay seventy-five thousand and
though the cool thing with capital and
venture points you can wipe off any
chart so you don't just use it for
airline or hotel you can on your uber
habit with your put it on your Capital
One and then you you literally take the
points and and they're worth the cent
apiece and you can wipe off charges like
so you can if you want to you can yes
you can so you can even use the capital
one venture card to pay for like an
airline ticket you earn points on the
airline for flying then you just wipe
the charger off your bill it's called
purchaser eraser it's super easy you
don't to jump through hoops so Capital
One now will have transfer partner
Airlines which we do a whole series on
how to get the most value if you want to
fly first-class okay which we do random
one more question what are your thoughts
on clear I love clear I did it because
if you find a Guardia like Orlando
Denver its they're just not in as many
airports as I'd like but clear is also
cool if you go to the Yankees game
instead of waiting in the long line you
put your tooth so clear for those of you
who don't know it even if you have TSA
PreCheck the lines can get long nowadays
clear you put two fingers on a sensor
and then they escort you to the front of
the TSA PreCheck line like how bougie is
that no it's okay but I didn't realize
you also need to have TSA PreCheck
because Margo I mean because you can
travel
with me my maid Margaret clear and she
didn't have pre-check are they're clear
they take you to the front of the
regular line still helpful that's denied
well I'm gonna get pre-check but that is
helpful to hundred dollars like if you
travel frequently if you're intimidating
you get 479 yeah so get it through Delta
it's like yeah it's good I like it it's
just an extra of me time is money I mean
at least for some of us successful
morning show host how long do you
recommend getting to the airport before
your flight six hours I messed eclis I
will show up I was I preach a kind clear
and stuff so I show up like 1 hour
before departure I don't recommend that
for most people like 30 minutes before
boarding I like to minimize my time well
cos for me I mean when I'm in an airline
lounge that's it's not exactly relaxing
treatment like an era not really I'm
still like I mean sometimes but not as
much as you'd think and I don't like I
don't ever let airlines know we don't
take any free but I'm like so not I hate
to yeah asking for favors me too
by the way can I get that jet ok you
guys make sure to head over to the point
sky.com slash shows follow along
tonight's gonna be so epic will all be
live instagramming you're gonna be all
over social right at Brian Kelly and at
the points guys to make sure to follow
gbg on instagram if you're a single gay
man slide into the empty ms cuz you know
you know the points guy is looking for
someone to share his bed with thank you
Brian I flipped out in the sky and we
can't wait to see all the looks
especially ours they're gonna be really
glamorous gonna die lit and with that we
will take a quick break and we will be
right back to deliver the fast 5 stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast so stay tuned go get a snack go to
the bathroom go to the points guy calm
slash to us and we'll see them
you
it's 11:11 make a wish I wish for the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast okay we're gonna
jump right into it Judith Jack I'm he
wind up from TPG and all of his
knowledge that I can't even wrap my head
around it's like so crazy what I don't
know Jackie that's what I said it's just
like he unites a fire within me I know
he doesn't even know like how obsessed
you are with it I know I think it's
better that we keep it that way for sure
I wasn't gonna um blow up my spot no not
at all
first story is really crazy someone
posted in the toasters last night and so
many people had different opinions on
him excited to hear yours
Kanye West slammed by the cher show
actor for texting an actor in the cher
show ripped Kanye West on Monday night
chiding the rapper for staring at his
cell phone during a performance
Jared Spectre who plays Cher's former
husband and musical companion Sonny Bono
in the Broadway musical tweeted at the
yeezus star after the show's debut hey
at Kanye West so cool that you're here
at at the cher show if you look up from
your cell phone you'll see we're doing a
show up here it's opening night kind of
a big deal for us
thanks so much he then replied he got a
tweety back to share and the Cher show
team the dynamics of Sharon Sonny's
relationship made Kim and I grab each
other's hand and saying I got you babe
please pardon my lack of etiquette we
have so much appreciation for the energy
you guys put into making this
masterpiece and then also his team set
to TMZ that he was taking notes on his
phone which I actually like kind of
believed and here's the thing I like
first of all this is like so thirsty on
behalf of the man who wrote it like now
everyone's talking about Jarrod Specter
and it's like who the hell is that you
know I don't know it's like I feel mixed
about it and like I said I might only
feel this way because I'm a Kim
apologist and defender till the death
and I don't know if someone else had if
they said Jacob sartorius was on his
phone like what I have the same opinion
I'm not sure but my opinion is this like
I hate when people like use their thirst
and their platforms like embarrass other
people um it's definitely rude like
there's no excuse for it as someone who
does performances and sees people on
their phone like it gets in your head
and it's like really annoying but it is
our job to rise above it and I have
never nor would I ever call someone out
for it either publicly or privately and
trust me there's been meet and greets
where I've wanted to be like oh
you're the [ __ ] who was talking in my
face and on your phone I know you [ __ ]
but what if it was Kanye doing it well I
would then leverage my position to be
like okay I could embarrass you but I'm
not going to so please be my friend and
like write a song for me or something
yeah I personally think it's a thirsty
move like being on your phone is rude
but they are doing a show on Brad a like
I'm assuming it's a big theater like how
are you even seeing that and you're
tweeting in the middle of the show - at
Kanye you're on your phone during the
show when you're performing yeah I don't
know you know it's like and he wrote
that tweet during the show how I guess
yeah exactly was he supposed to be an
extra in the background just like on his
phone
I don't know but or he maybe he wrote it
after but I just think he was like
really thirsty and and rude to call him
out so publicly as opposed to just like
talking [ __ ] back stage with the other
actors but they they're both wrong like
Kanye's shouldn't have been on its own
it's [ __ ] rude like and it pisses me
off but like I don't know to publicly
embarrass someone and then like now this
guys getting retweets because not
because of him because of Kanye like
that just makes me annoyed I don't know
I I ever they're all wrong I think Kanye
responded with grace and elegance and
that's the only way you can do it I
agree and happy to put it to bed but it
was definitely a little crazy the
theater is just but I feel like I can
speak to this just because I've been
definitely the person in the audience on
their front and they've also been the
person performing who sees people on
their phone and it distracts you and it
gets in your head so I feel like I I can
I can say stuff you know yeah you feel
I've experienced you're unbiased
okay next story really crazy people are
freaking out tumblr will ban all adult
content on December 17 okay and I was
shook to the core by this and it it
realized the impetus behind it is
because they were removed from the app
store because of all the porn you're not
there's no pornhub app you're not
allowed to have porn in the App Store
because kids have access to it and I
have the tumblr app because of my Taylor
Swift tumblers 50 with no job and it
[ __ ] disappeared and I was so
confused and then I read this and I'm
like oh I was affected by this piece a
little piece of news therefore making
everything about myself yes so tumblr
will permanently ban adult content from
its platform on December 17th in a move
that will eradicate porn related
communities on the platform and
fundamentally alter how the service is
used very true the ban includes explicit
sexual content in nudity
with a few exceptions the company tells
The Verge the new policies announcement
comes just days after tumblr was removed
from the App Store over a child
pornography incident but extends far
beyond that matter alone quote adult
content will no longer be allowed here
the company flatly stated in the blog
post published Monday ban content
includes photos videos and gifts of
human genitalia female presenting
nipples and any media involving sex acts
including illustrations so that anime
cartoon broken so what's so crazy is
that like they're literally like this
this affects a lot of people like porn
on tumblr it's like a huge community so
I just think it's kind of wild I think
it's wild so I think it's a bold move
but I understand I mean you have to
choose between like being the porn
platform or being on the app store or
being the Taylor Swift platform right
tumblr it's just like a dark place in
general like I feel like you only go to
tumblr like when you're in a dark time
yeah but I feel like they also have a
really great community so I feel like
this kind of goes against the community
and what they're doing cuz when I think
of the porn that's on there it's not
necessarily like porn it's I mean it is
you know but you an import but no-one's
like making like sex seeds it's like
gifts of like no it needs nice porn porn
oh really yeah well I was I had to go
looking after I'm so it's just like
girls with their side but no I know no
no no like there is a porn community
where like porn is distributed videos
ships like a hardcore [ __ ] is just when
I used to I started my blog on tumblr so
I used to be like in on tumblr and I was
I used to have like a like a country
themed tumblr and I would get country
music and every now and then you extend
upon literally like penises and you're
like what and it's hard porn it's like
legit yeah so I guess as a company they
had to make the decision what direction
they want to go and and they went with
the kids they went with the kids and
they'll be in the app store still so I
just think it's so wild is this already
being implemented or they have a date
when all the porn gets assembly when all
the porn is gone so you know catch up on
it now yeah get it while you can
that is just so funny because it's just
like it's not like there's a you know a
limited amount of porn on the internet
like we'll all be okay the people who
need porn can still find it off of
tumblr yes but I think it's like not
only is it porn but it's like the
community community yeah no it's like
it's really the
camaraderie that they're gonna miss
right and I think that that's a real
thing thing and people will be upset but
I'm sure you'll find somewhere else I'm
to band together in agreement ok next
story broke yesterday after the toasts
Pete Davidson broke his silence and
Ariana Grande just responded does your
article have the new update cuz I just
saw it on the nose I just have them Pete
statement and then all gonna Daria I'm
gonna read info because I think it
deserves that I've kept my mouth shut
never mentioned any names never said a
word about anyone or anything I'm trying
to understand how when something happens
to a guy the whole entire world just
trashes him without any facts or frame
of reference especially in today's
climate where everyone loves to be
offended and upset is it is truly
mind-boggling I've been getting on the
online bullied and in public by people
for nine months I've spoken about BPD
and being suicidal publicly only in the
hope seda will help bring awareness and
help kids like myself who don't want to
be on this earth I just want you guys to
know no matter how hard the internet or
anyone tries to make me kill myself I
won't I'm upset I even have to say this
to all those holding me down and seeing
this for what it is I see you and I love
you so basically he was speaking
directly to Ariana's fans who I'm sure
have been inundated him with really
[ __ ] mean messages and Arianna just
released a statement 59 minutes ago to
her fans about Pete saying to her fans
please let whatever point you're trying
to make it go I will always have a
revocable love for him and if you've
gotten any other impression for my
recent work you might have missed the
point so she is cooperating I feel like
as weird and like tumultuous and crazy
as their relationship was I feel like
they definitely spoke a lot openly about
like mental health because they both
have been through a lot so I feel like
she is always gonna be like receptive
and open to like helping him through
stuff like that right and regardless of
even it's like it ended badly people
shouldn't be telling him to go kill
himself you shouldn't tell anyone to go
kill themselves but especially someone
who's been so open about their struggles
totally this is like really me and and
but when you think about it it's like
they're it's like even the most famous
people in the world
read the comments yeah that's really
what I learned today I mean it's it's
impossible not to unless you're not on
social media and also I feel like not
only is he saying this for himself like
he doesn't wanna see it anymore but that
stuff like just shouldn't be out there
just cuz you love someone's music
doesn't mean that they're at
boyfriend has to kill themselves you
know totally look I'd love Ariana and
I'm definitely taking her side and
whatever like happy with her people like
p-please don't kill yourself like that's
a normal response he's a cool dude
and he's right people get offended by
the things that he says all the time and
then people say these things to him and
it's okay Britt so it's like why are we
all held to different standards and
there's different things for what other
people can say right I agree that's a
valid point Pete it's a valid point
I agree we're just breezing through the
stories but it's because obviously I
only had time for the points got today
and we have to talk about Vanderpump
rules yes and my exterminators coming oh
yeah and I have a very busy day next
story is really crazy fraternities
sororities are suing Harvard over single
sex Club crackdown a group of u.s.
fraternities and sororities on Monday
sued Harvard University saying its
crackdown on single sex clubs amounted
to sexual discrimination in lawsuits
filed in federal and state courts in
Boston the group challenged a policy
that the Ivy League university adopted
in 2016 and began enforcing this
academic year that Harvard said was
intended to end long-standing practices
of exclusion at the elite school Harvard
has long sought to stamp out single sex
clubs which had stopped formally
recognizing in 1984 but groups known as
final clubs informal social clubs a
student as a student group of students
before graduating as well as some frats
and sororities have continued to operate
off-campus under the policy students who
join these clubs may not serve as
captains of sports teams or leaders of
officially recognized student clubs and
cannot receive endorsement letters from
college dean for post graduate
fellowships what are your thoughts that
is the lamest thing ever why is every
college trying to get rid of
fraternities and sororities and I know
I've seen the SVU episodes I know that a
lot of times bad things happen at four
turnings and they answer artists too and
those things need to be amended but it's
like stop fighting it it's like a part
of college culture like the fact that
Harvard doesn't have fraternities and
sororities like what do they do there
you know yeah well they have like all
these other clubs and you get punished
for being a part of it yes oh no but
then there are other clubs that you
don't get punished for being a part of
but the thing about fraternities and
sororities yes on the one hand it's
there's that whole culture of like you
know it's not always a safe place hazing
but I think what Harvard's trying to get
at is like they do
except fraternities because they want to
allow women and they don't accept
sororities because they won't allow men
and they want to end that that there's
just groups based on gender okay I mean
I guess but like sometimes it's nice to
just hang out with girls and sometimes
it's nice to just hang out with guys and
it's not any more serious or less
serious than that Harvard and yeah I
don't think they should be punished
academically do you think you you do
here Travis Scott is applying to Harvard
I'm gonna meeting he'll be in my class
that's what I said are you gonna see him
at the clambake he would be the second
Travis to go to Harvard this year second
- Travis Holmen totally me Travis Holmen
and Travis Scott will be at the clambake
trips to the Cape oh and you know what
we won't join a fraternity or sorority
because we'll be in our own Club that's
mixed gender and it's like celebrity
mixed gender I don't know now that
fraternities and sororities are really
weird because they are like a real big
piece of like American culture and
history but they're not super inclusive
and it's like we have our own sorority
right now and anyone can join that's
true I mean them being okay them being
okay sorry here's the other thing is
then being created based on gender okay
fine maybe but is that is the answer to
get rid of them no just tell them to be
more inclusive right like if a girl
wants to join a fraternity like let her
rush yeah or or anyone who identifies as
anything and let there be single sex
sororities and mixed sex two sorority
yeah like if we never as a woman if I
want to be a part of sorority that's
only including women that should be
allowed but it's not a woman who wants
to be a part of a sorority that's much
more inclusive that should be allowed to
there should be all types single gender
co-ed mickus gender no gender they
should start a new sorority well they
need a new word so it'd be like a
sorority that works yeah that's mixed
that sounds fun I think it's a good idea
I just think them being removed solely
for the reason that they're single sex
is stupid because there's a remedy we
can fix it yeah I can make it better not
get rid of it totally kiss it kiss it
better baby
and it's like all these kids are
students at Harvard you know what's
killing them that they can't be the
captain of the team Oh like for me it's
like oh I wouldn't be affected by any of
these girls doesn't like to be the
captain of a club or a team but it's
like these weenies who work at our whole
lives like chanta Harvard are now at
Harvard they're not giving up now no
they're not and like getting a letter
from the D
like for job recommendations like drew
that stuff that actually means something
that's my craziness I can't like it's so
crazy college campuses are really such a
like a hostile a hotbed of like real
pertinent issues yeah their God of
control though sometimes like sometimes
the [ __ ] I hear about happening on
college campuses like it's so out of
control that like I just need to go over
there and teach those [ __ ] a lecture
you need to teach them a lecture and
give him a lecture ya know there I have
so many thoughts on oncologist but then
I also don't I don't know you know you
know what I also didn't go to a real
college like I speak on literally no
experience or knowledge sorry about that
but then even at Colgate like since I've
graduated so many things have changed
and he really even though it was only
like six years ago it feels it seems
like a different school completely yeah
well and not always her the worst but I
also like this school that I went to
right but then I also there are things
that I would definitely you know about
times there chit chit to change in
turning face to change just gonna have
to be a different girl time day changed
me but I can't change time what a
pertinent song Wow our fifth and final
story we're just cruising you guys the
most downloaded iOS apps of 2018 social
media dominated the top app city of the
Year on Tuesday Apple unveiled its list
of the most downloaded iPhone apps of
2018 topping the list is YouTube
followed by Instagram snapchat messenger
and Facebook respectively well you tube
was first posed a sec on Instagram okay
then snapchat then messenger can
Facebook Messenger is above Facebook but
I think it's because people already have
these but this is like we're and they
forced us to get it this year
right then like releasing two apps is
one of the most annoying things ever
they've released an app for everything
they also if you've a paged you want to
moderate your page everything it's like
you need a separate app and that is a
big mistake so we're stuck with
marketplace in the main app but give us
messages or give us death bitmoji a
snapchat owned app that lets users
create an emoji that looks like them
dropped to sixth place on the list
it was the most downloaded app last year
Wow that makes sense because it has to
do with snapchats fall from grace and
now
have me no genes so you know never need
bitmoji again it's been a challenging
year for some social media companies
such as Facebook which has faced
criticism over privacy issues data
misused misinformation and election
meddling on its platforms nevertheless
Facebook's pelagic flagship app and two
others owned by the company Instagram
and messenger made the top five of the
most downloaded downloaded list oh yeah
I forgot that Instagram is on me and
that it it owns everything Facebook
snapchat also face challenges this year
including navigating a controversial
redesign that was widely panned by users
and heightened competition from
Instagram which has copied many of its
popular features once again the most
popular paid app was self editing tool
facetune and kira kira which lets you
add cool effects to videos and photos
that's acting craziest thing that is Ida
had no clue that that was two years in a
row now the most popular paid app is
face tune that says so I pay for it too
of course yeah but that says something
no that's it's a stunning indictment of
the culture we currently are in what
other apps do we pay for I don't pay
well so if you go to your iTunes in your
settings it tells you everything you pay
for it I paid for it for a while to
YouTube's premium so I could download
videos offline and that's literally it
I need to check because maybe facetune
is the only app I pay for like making it
now has everyone paid up um
Apple declined to say how many times the
apps have been downloaded in gaming it
was no surprise that fortnight topped
the charts the number two spot went to
Hilux jump a game in which players
navigate a falling ball through a maze
that was followed by right okay really
yeah I always have on the air oh my god
Ben has 1,000 games on his phone for the
airplane
interesting it's the lousiest thing ever
I had no clue by the way um me and Ben
are sending out holiday cards I know and
I got your address you I'll give you my
address if there's not a picture of Theo
on it Chucky what do you think I'm not
even on it Theo's on it it's other just
happy holidays from the cutest most
precious most superstitious delicious
nutritious boy in the world happy
picture of Theo Happy Holidays
here's her gift me my presence is a
present right frame used our toast frame
this I used our promo code like honestly
if these days ever since like we started
partnering with these wonderful brands
like if I'm purchasing something and
there's no promo code I won't click it
no I know it's so hard for me now
because then I'm spoils up hurts to
something and then we'll get a promo
code or we'll do so we'll do a deal with
a brand I'm like trekker can I can this
be retroactive but so we have a promo
code for vistaprint which I use for my
holiday cards and I know a lot of you
send out holiday cards so we thought it
was pertinent that we get this out ASAP
what's the come they have hundreds of
card designs from timeless classics to
the latest trends they also have custom
calendars for a year worth of memories
you can be like Kylie and make your own
calendar that's honestly so cool so get
married get jolly get 15% off all
holiday cards and calendars plus save on
other photo gifts at vistaprint.com
just enter promo code toast holiday
that's vistaprint.com promo code toast
holiday offer valid until January 31st
2019 for those of you who are gonna be a
little delayed in your holiday cards
yeah no it's great also but holiday
cards can go throughout New Year's can
you could say Happy New Year from the
stoppers totally I like a Happy New Year
me too it's less like I suppose she
because we're Jewish so we can't do like
cute Christmas no I do a Hanukkah card
nondenominational way to go yeah no
totally Happy Holidays not Merry
Christmas
happy holidays and a happy new year too
soon to like start getting out of cabs I
mean like Merry Christmas
I don't maybe but then if you say Happy
Holidays it's not too soon because we're
in the holidays Hanukkah started okay so
after wait ready after our trip to Utah
we got back here Utah
Thursday was Thanksgiving through the
weekend we did our first show back here
on Wednesday when I got here that lovely
guy who sits outside open the door for
me and I was like thank you Happy
Thanksgiving
almost six days after actual
Thanksgiving what's that weird I felt
really weird about it I don't think
there's anything weird about it cuz
you're at the end of they are saying
like a nice greeting you know yeah
ending your mind is still Thanksgiving
and I wish it could be Thanksgiving
every day but then I would be 1,000
pounds me [ __ ] to wait also did you
watch banner from pearls let me done
with the story we're done with the
stories I want to talk about Vanderpump
rules because I'm so happy it's back
know me too and it's a show like I've
fallen really behind a lot of my
Housewives and I'm catching up currently
but it is a show that's a full priority
for me so much so that I'm my [ __ ] DD
are literally recorded one minute of it
and I watched it live at 11:30 with
commercials and it was really annoying
but I did it and I just have like so
many thoughts and you know who was
really [ __ ] annoying me
Kristen Dodie because she almost ruined
the proposal yeah
and I get that she has intuition but if
you do and it's about the bride stop
[ __ ] touching the bride it's at 1000%
she was a really annoying me that was
really annoying also they waited so long
to release the season and so much has
happened like when Stassi said that she
broke up with Patrick he broke up with
her on their Orianna her dream
I remember when all that happened I
Instagram that Mexico so long ago now I
know
Sex in the City you've got like they had
a trip to Mexico plan so she went with
Rachel O'Brien when she was like
starting to cry just talking about beau
I love both so much and I love her beau
and I just like need them to like be
together forever I know nothing about
beau except that I love him give me two
and like she is herself with him and she
seems so happy she looks so happy she
looks so good she looks so healthy and
like fresh so fresh all of their spray
tans
I was really noticing spray tan so I
sent me because we got one but it's like
all of them are spray tan to perfection
but then they have like red ears you
know it's funny like and then also under
their eyelids you like it's like the
color of their actual skin it's like a
little red and it really is a crash
course in spray tanning that little
thing Brittany had to do her makeup
I need that no totally the lights in the
mirror and you could sit while you're
doing it can you watch watch what
happens live I watched the second half
watch up and live and when Andy gave
them a toaster message we see each other
we see each chef yeah she was so cute
cuz everyone was asking why she's
wearing gloves to eat her sandwich and
put on makeup yeah what's she doing tan
no she said she gets really bad eczema
and she had terrible eczema on her palms
and she had all these cuts on her
fingers so she can't if she touched
makeup it would like infect it well she
looks a little different on watch up
inside less and in a good way
address at the top of the show she got
an emergency root canal the day before
so for Amalfi her mouth is all messed up
oh it's so interesting looked she's oh
so happy on watch what happens live
she was giggling smile and like she's
always been a happy person but in now
seeing her this way I see how she was
like struggling before I can't believe
like everyone on the show is also like
experiencing some sort of death when it
rains it pours it's so true and comes in
threes right and like every time la la'
talks about her dad like I just want to
cry like I feel so bad same with Jax
like just I wanted to cry last night but
we just had spray tans and it would have
ruined my face I'm so [ __ ] like
annoyed with James and like either
reckoning times up on James Kennedy like
I'm ready for it but here's the thing
about
James the cast is all cool right now so
if James wasn't like spitting bars about
Brittany what would this episode have
been about it we're almost like to make
they have to always have a Dylan and I
think that James like he's recognizes
that he's a villain he's happy to play
the role happy to be on TV and is just
doing things to get reactions out of
people so that like the show goes on but
what he doesn't realize it's like we
don't even need that in order to enjoy
this show where the hell machinae she
like wasn't in the episode something
like learning with that guide the work
of the restaurant and like I was going
to know I cringe season yeah we have
like the same hair like who the [ __ ]
wants to date someone with same hair ism
no she was it was cringy or and that's
what she was complaining about when the
tease when that trailer came back she's
like I'm down the trailer I'm like are
you really [ __ ] complaining they're
not in the trailer but now I kind of see
why she's on the show also Jackson
Brittany's proposal was so sweet
but the way that Bravo filmed it made it
like they were trying to like shade the
fact there were other people there that
it was like you know what sort of order
and go and then I want to have inside
they explain the significance on the of
the place and they chose not to put that
in the episode like that this is where
they always go they love like clams they
love the beach and that it meant so much
to them and they could have said that in
the episode completely agree and because
my DVR malfunctioned the only thing it
recorded by the last four minutes of the
actual proposal and I didn't see that
they were in Malibu by the ocean I just
saw this drive through so I'm like what
the [ __ ] and then when I rewatched I'm
like oh wait that's so cute it was
gorgeous really cute restaurant by the
ocean yes he should have gotten up and
gone to the beach and like looked at the
ocean and then did it there but whatever
he was so nervous and it was so cute he
couldn't find anywhere to put the box
and by the way that's such a relatable
thing and Ben had the same problem and
then got they make these bought their
flat boxes and it's when you open it it
turns the ring up and Ben was like this
when he got it he like thought he was so
special and he was like look it's a real
problem
Wow but yeah they mean I should not
engage at a McDonald's and it's like
even if I agree they should have told us
that the McDonald's is significant to
them for a real specific reason and she
just seemed so so happy like and I love
that it wasn't super extra because it's
a season opener you know the whole cast
should be there like big party whatever
and I'm sure he had all that pressure to
do it that way and he still chose to
like make it really sell between the two
and then they go back to their apartment
next week
huge party and when she was like are we
going to what was the bar that Jack IOD
coyotes like shut up [ __ ] shucks the
after-party surprise oh my god I wanted
to kill her I was saying but like Stassi
needed to rip Kristen's phone out of her
hands but I couldn't get Stassi keep a
secret no I don't know like I would have
been fine I would have just been hired
maybe she's like at that point you can
tell them because it's happening curling
yeah I thought it was cute that they
chose to tell Stassi meet a oh I just
love Stassi I love sexy team I'm gonna
just love Lola my only complaint about
the episode was not enough Lala Oh
completely she looks so good with dark
hair like she needs to be the one with
the most air time I don't care I'll
watch her go to the supermarket go to
the gym and now she's like she said his
name she called him by his name say my
name same name
um yeah I'll watch Lalo do pretty much
anything if you guys need to fill screen
time like just throw it was actually
thinking before I went to bed like I
would watch a la la' show see like a 30
minute and it's so crazy because when
she died her hair brown and was on
Instagram and stuff I was like oh I kind
of missed the blonde but like she looks
incredible on the show all the time yeah
and it's hard to look good on the show
like because you're filming in daylight
and you're sweaty and you don't have
hair and makeup like it's hard but those
those scenes like the commentary like
that is a set with set lighting and set
makeup and that it's easy to look at it
but it's hard to look good on a reality
show like that's why I don't want one
1,000% also I love Jax I love new Jax
he's gonna judge oh good I'm watching my
vibe and I loved when Tom Sandoval who's
clearly likes just very immature was
like I hope you proposing to her has
nothing to do with your dad died totally
he was like of course it does man by the
way I loved I love Jax he's so like sure
of himself and decisions and like
usually he'd be like oh oh is this a bad
thing why should do that right and he
was like of course and glad I said that
I was like why not you really get to see
like who people really are and like how
they are there for you when you need
them to be there these are the moments
in life that matter I couldn't anything
else does what she does when he's like
going to the club like doesn't matter
no I'm literally over Tom Sandoval me
too and the way he talks about Tom Tom
like I want to kill him oh my god please
no more time Tom no more business
meetings I said we were done with that
last season Jackie when they opened up
the show going to sur I'm like why go to
stassi's apartment
I can't with like the forced at least a
banner probably Jax has to beg for his
job back I can't
you know the show really needs to move
past like let's address the fact they're
making a lot of money Britney's ring is
[ __ ] huge like how do you make that
on a waiter salary like let's address
their rich now they're somewhat famous
they live in nicer apartments like let's
go that they're not waiters anymore I
don't want that and then there are also
some Ernie's they go to sir because now
they are like public figures of sir
people go home to see you next Tuesday
they all the cast is all there like it's
more of a thing you don't have to
pretend like you're really bussing
tables
I'm with scheana talking to the working
actor who's pretending to be a patron at
Vanderpump rules restaurant right oh so
when Jax said that his dad left him a
little bit of money and he spent it on
birdies ring so every time he looks at
it it could be a reminder of him like
the most beautiful like I I would never
even think of that and I need to start
looking up for my phone I miss that I I
would never even be like deep enough to
think of that and so I am we've always
been teen tracks and I've always felt
that the man in real life is different
than the person on the show cuz he used
to be a James and the fact that he knew
what he was doing and just was keeping
the show going and now he's really grown
up and I love him and I love Brittany
and I love them together and them on
watch what happens live last night was
so beautiful really like I'm touched by
that I didn't hear that he left him a
little bit of money and he spent it all
on the ring
they're so cute I I really can't so
excited for this season just bring me
more Lala and we'll be good
yeah no I'm there they always even on
like a lull of a season they always turn
it up so like that every time I watch
them it makes me want to go out and
drink with my friends like I don't know
why they like ignite dislike millennial
like party girl at me no totally and
they they just go out and take shots
like all the time honestly I love it I
really just might like go out with them
once and it's and it's just a day in the
life for them it's like the way that we
I don't know go get a snack ready is the
way they're gonna get shots yeah if you
could have to give up shots or snacks
what would you do shots I guess because
you could get drunk in other ways I have
so much to do before TBG I'm getting my
eyebrows done I have to buy a pair of
shoes I'm getting a manicure of my hair
and my makeup done so like I've got to
go I've got to go thank you so much for
tuning in we will be back tomorrow we're
gonna post the link for the point Skype
credit cards if you actually
want to just learn more about them and
find out where you can sign up and get
all those special perks it's the point
sky.com slash choice we'll post it in
the group on the page on twitter
facebook Instagram whatever you'll be
able to find it so don't worry about
that also once you do get to the page if
you are in you audio if you're in New
York or the surrounding tri-state area
and you can get here by 7:30 tonight
there is a giveaway for two tickets to
the 22 words there's a little go to the
site you'll see okay so basically on the
site there are random letters that are
highlighted and I need you guys to find
those letters unscramble them and there
is a toastie clue the first person to
comment who lives in New York and can
make it tonight the first person to
comment what the clue was wins so head
over to the point sky.com
forward slash toast find the letters
scramble them up comment see you tonight
we'll be there we got a cute photo you
get two tickets you and a plus-one
it's gonna be a good time the more
points guy calm /the toast only if
you're available to attend the awards
tonight can't wait to see you there
we're back tomorrow ma
you